okay the goal is to win one game
so oh he's playing a french
wait what do i play against the french
i could play the ortho schnapp i'm gonna
play the ortho schnapp
i wonder if he's seen the ortho schnapp
before
lorthos drop is like a dubious gambit
against the french
popularized by jonathan trotz
i'm so curious if he's seen this before
it's a funny line the idea is after it
takes to play bishop c4
if knight f6 i play e5 and
like it's nice against low rated players
to trick them into a more open position
because french players usually like
close positions
i like the fact he's thinking
so at the very least it'll lead to a
time advantage
i'm pretty sure this line is like close
to equal
basically we're going to get a structure
with d4 bishop d3
and we could transpose into some like e4
openings
so yeah i really can't complain with
this
he shook okay that's great to hear
whatever that means
struck with fear like queen c2 here
i mean i really want to get d4 in
asap
and then this one and this and then this
uh
oh that's interesting so he's gonna try
i feel like i had a similar line
recently
i might try to take at some point
let's be brave this pawn could be an
eventual target because it can't be
defended by
any neighboring pawn but it can be
defended by the bishop
i'm allowing this but i don't mind the
double pawns it would strengthen the
center
and i think i just want a complete
development
enjoy the space advantage enjoy
being alive
also yeah thanks everyone for watching
um i know there's
it's hard to play and interact at least
play at a high level
um i forgot to ask if if we're actually
on the front page because we might be
but we might not be if anyone's like
watching from the front page
uh welcome this is chess it's not quite
fall guys
or among us
but it's close enough we take this pawn
for free
oh c5 is really annoying
um play this move queen a4 knight c6
bishop b5
just trying to exert pressure i think
i'll start with bishop e5
and decide whether to play queen a4
[Music]
hmm it's not entirely what i want
but you can't always get what you
entirely want
oh thank you t-con celebration bits i am
proud of being a part of the best twitch
community thanks so much
really appreciate that and t kong has
one of my favorite usernames
every time i see tikang i have to drink
some tea
there's a lot of pressure here in both
of us trying to
apply maximum pressure
considering queenside castling actually
it's kind of weird but maybe kind of
good
because i'm keeping the option open of
rook g1 defending the pawn which could
be
helpful in certain lines
stream chess today for the first time
how do you manage reading chat and not
flagging
wait okay i have to focus time is
running low
i'm not the best at reading chat and
calculating at the same time
let's try i'll try this
and probably i'm probably just gonna
hunker down
maybe
[Music]
he's playing good moves give
oh give oh
uh wait let's not flag
so i'm trying to win this pawn i'm close
to winning the pawn
if bishop takes i win the pawn
my time management wait really
takes takes takes
yeah this thing is pinned i mean he
could stack maybe and then takes and
then takes and
takes in rook d2 and takes and defend
and attack but then i played this
[Music]
not sure what's going on here but it
looks fun
i mean so far all these games have been
like one big lesson
at least for me
to take this way i can also take with
pawn
oh i'm allowing this at least i have
this
lock's going to take and i play king b1
or not
play this move
that's kind of annoying oh that's really
annoying
i'm losing the pawn but always play king
b1
knight f2 coming f2 i take or maybe even
rook g1
rook g1 is kind of clever
not happening though player g1 here
threatening mate
hide the king
that was a really bad move i think wait
what
what's going on
what's going on here no my position ah
i think i'm just losing wow
i should have played e6 to prevent rook
b8 i just didn't have enough time
wow gg ah he keeps feeding me
okay i i need to recover a little bit
from that game
i like the position though like
especially around here
my g5 is clever this whole night walk
maneuver
like this light found a really cool path
this was good all right let's move on to
the next one the fun
the fun game uh the it's ortho schnapp
yeah
yeah so i played the opening for 30
years and still got surprised you know
i've played the french for 30 years guys
and still it was a
surprise so i realized if i take the
pawn it's gonna
be a chaos and uh maybe i can i can
blunder and lose so i played knight f6
yeah so we should note like this this is
a critical line like bishop c4
queen queen d7 is the best move g7 is
the best one okay i was wondering
if i can play knight h6 with knight h6
that's probably d3 or
i i would imagine i i honestly don't
know so much theory i just kind of play
like try and play aggressively it makes
sense something like d3 open up the
position you know
yeah so yeah queen d7 yeah this
i don't think i'll be comfortable with
this because it's just you know
it's it's very hard to play you know
right right that's fine
okay all right
um anyway you play knight f6 which is
kind of the secondary move
and then it leads to kind of this
interesting structure
and we got a situation where i think
like there is just a lot of pressure
against each side
yeah yeah i was very happy with the
opening outcome to be honest but then
later on
i think you played really well because i
thought i was doing
very well here but i think your moves
are very precise this queen a4 knight c3
and i'm missing that one tempe you know
like one tempe sure
uh if i had castle then i'm very very
comfortable here
but but i i didn't manage to do that
yeah i mean usually like
going for the pin in these structures
isn't so great for white because it
like at some moment you'll have a6 and
i'm going to have to trade in your favor
but somehow like i managed to justify it
you managed yeah i think it's
okay so i took oh by the way this is
important detail because if if you're
wondering
like if take i have this take this is i
think important which i've yeah
i saw yeah which should lose a piece
yeah this is important detail and take
okay
did this i'm just missing my castle if i
if i had canceled here guys essentially
black is just winning here
if black is castle but this tactic is
very
it's right on time basically so first i
was
i was looking at this line i was looking
at this
i don't know if you saw this idea it was
very interesting
take fake right and remove knight c5
so the only thing i didn't see knight c5
i saw the maybe the possibility of you
taking
uh rook t2 and then taking and defending
but
yeah um is interesting yeah it's
interesting but i realize if i do this
uh since you're alone time then you if
nothing else you would just take
take and play king b1 and i have zero
winning chances
here that's true i mean i have zero
winning chances here
and you know maybe i can make a draw
here okay
so so that's why i
choose not to play but just the move
itself is kind of interesting that in
the middle
of this you can actually play uh is
there queen g4
uh queen g4 and it might lead to
something similar
i'm just thinking queen space yeah yeah
yeah it's probably just not good it's
just just the idea was uh
it was interesting okay so let's move on
to the
the game uh
so i like the position i got but then uh
like it still got tricky and your night
was so
so devious i thought you could just take
no i thought this is what you
could do yeah i mean and that's a simple
move i just thought okay i can maintain
the pin and keep the attack against your
queen
yeah i thought this this is fine and
maybe even something like this you know
and just
start start slowly consolidating i think
i have some compensation here
and for blitz game maybe it's not that
bad but i think uh yeah it's
uh yeah it could still be sharp with
offsets side castling but yeah yeah
so but now and and and now i blundered
queen e3 i had queen e3 check
right which i was expecting yeah but but
now this night
it became a little bit tricky no this
was really annoying especially with like
under five seconds left yeah you had no
time and this night the guys that's why
this night is a tricky piece you know
it's always like jumping around
and creating tricky stuff
so i played yeah and i have to like stay
defending this pawn
yeah but then i'm also having to defend
against the forks
so i just gave you the pawn yeah
and and it's just a little bit easier
for me to play you know somehow because
i think the king um i
i'm wondering if maybe you could play
like the problem is knight d3 is coming
it's it's really annoying
uh oh maybe maybe f4 eric
can you do this to kind of
because i think you can just consolidate
yeah you need to consolidate once you
consolidate you you'll be absolutely
fine
so something like this and
it's of course it's important not to
blunder in this position you know like
sure you need to blunder something here
um
this is one of my biggest problems is
like especially in increment games i'll
get too complacent
i'll get low on time and then in these
situations i'm living on increments
sometimes i'll just panic and
yeah yeah i think even now see where
we're looking for like
you know 10-15 seconds it's not easy to
see it's hard to find like a logical
move
because that's the thing when you guys
playing blitz the initiative is the key
and you know you always sometimes
material not as important it's just
which position it's easier to play for
which side it's hard to see i'm sure
i'm sure there's a good defensive move
here i mean rickoff i mean
someone in my chat is suggesting rook f1
which almost traps the knights
i guess we have queen d3 or knight oh 93
even stronger yeah
knight is the main threat yeah the main
threat in the position knight d3
so this is the problem and i was i'm
actually looking i think i
play rock g22
there's there's some rook b8 yeah but
rook b8 maybe
maybe i can get away with taking the
knight
no it's rook b2 queen c1 is a mate oh
yeah that's
that's a good point it's right here so
um
it's not an easy position i mean it's
not easy yeah it's it's not easy guys
it's not easy to see
it's not easy to see uh
all right let's see yeah in the game
like i guess your attack actually like
yeah yeah it was just yeah i got
then i just took i didn't calculate
everything but it just felt like
this was maybe the the right way to go
of course maybe i can play rook b8 but i
didn't want to allow f4
so maybe there was a defense so i
like it aft right after the game i
realized i can play e6 here to cover b8
of course of course it's a nice resource
my my yeah my my attack was just a
you know bluff i guess uh i missed c6 of
course
yeah here position is really good here
for me of course but i have to
play play a little bit differently maybe
i just have to
uh play just 95 i guess
because you you you do want to play or
wait maybe rook b8
ah still this e6 maybe
yeah he succeeds in a few of these lines
okay they have this trick but i don't
know if it's gonna work
because if you take i have a check and
then knight b1 queen b one mate and then
but uh i'm not sure but maybe i can just
ignore it
now you take but then oh yeah
yeah queen c7 is landing and it's gonna
be very strong so i think
it's going to be very unpleasant so i'm
not sure because
if if if let's say i take
check
if i go up you have queen c6 check if i
go back
uh let's see i mean at the very least i
should have perpetual
you should have some perpetual here yeah
at least
yeah it's a weird uh yeah weird
situation it's important to check from
here though
because if king h6 you have queen quit
h3 exactly because if
let's say you're giving quick checks
that's what happens all the time you
play quick checks in a blitz and then
opponent somehow hides and then there's
no more checks so
giving accurate checks is important here
all right
yeah so yeah somehow yeah i missed
easter we both missed this
uh idea yeah i mean i
had choose 2.6 seconds to make a move
here so
but but yeah also i don't know why i
didn't do this at least
so i was expecting rook v8 and then king
c4 and uh
yeah but i'm not sure oh you win the
night i take this guy i think it's
yeah you can probably end up winning
he's probably just winning
take yeah then this this this this queen
end games are pretty much always
hopeless because
the pawns are covering the king and they
just put a queen here and just start
start pushing it's very hard to get
contra play